hello my name is Martin Kik and I'm from
Poland and I'm an outro of an
independent online program about
International politics and today I will
have a pleasure of talking to Marin
Marin B um unfortunately we will talk
about very serious topic human
trafficking something that for many
Europeans may sound like a marginal
problem or problem of the past or
problem of some distant countries
unfortunately it is still reality of our
European union and Union wants to change
that by creating new law so before we
get into specifics could you please tell
us more about the main objectives main
goals of this new LW uh actually it is a
revision of an already existing
directive from 2011 but as with all law
it was time to update this European law
and uh as you also pointed out this is
something that we would have hoped uh
should be be uh be eradicated but
trafficking in human being and in
particular trafficking in women and
girls for sexual exploitation continues
to to be an a serious issue in the
European Union and we also see that the
the responses that we've had so far have
not been efficient and effective enough
so that's the background to the the
proposal to revise the directive and I
can discuss with you a little bit more
the the main points of that revision if
uh later on
yes and you are talking about the
position of European Parliament but
could you please tell us where are we
with this law when it comes to
legislative process because well I've
read to through the proposals of
European Parliament but I I also read a
uh position of European Council uh from
May if I remember correctly and goals
may be similar but these are two very
much different approaches different
legal acts so could you tell us about
the main contention points between
Parliament and countries and between
European Council and is it possible that
this whole procedure will not come into
conclusion because you know the
Parliamentary term is coming to an
end well uh uh if I start by the the
last um uh I would say doubt or or fears
that that that some of some some people
might have uh when it relates to the
legislative processes in in um in in um
in line here now it goes for this file
but and for many others that of course
we have this end date of of the end of
this legislature where if we are not
finished a new Parliament a new
commission will have and a new you know
the council continues as it is but you
know in have to to pick up this file so
uh on the one hand I think and I
strongly believe that we will be able to
finish during this uh legislature we
have now the Spanish presidency
negotiating very hard negotiating very
you know hard with us and then we will
have the Belgian presidency so I'm I'm
I'm quite optimistic but should that not
happen then the legislative file will
belong to the next Parliament and to the
next you know co-legislators so that's
one point but the other point is that of
course as in many files the European
Parliament and the the council we have
different positions we have made
different emphasis and we are also have
I would say in this case very different
levels of ambition uh when it boils down
to it and in me together with my
co-rapporteur mariaa Rodriguez palop
from Spain I'm from the gender equality
committee here in the European
Parliament I'm from the civil liberties
committee we decided very early that we
wanted to be a little bit more ambitious
than the commission proposal we want you
know to be more ambitious when it comes
to
prevention so preventing this crime from
happening in the first place and that
means a set of actions that we have to
to engage in it means that we have to
work with uh education awareness Rising
we have to strengthen gender equality
mechanism we have to strengthen child's
protection mechanism so that women girls
and children do not even end up in this
situation we have to put more
responsibility on online platforms Etc
so that's one other the part more
ambitious Parliament position compared
to the council and then the other is
protection of victims when the crime
happens you know what are their services
what are their protection what is the
support to victims how do we treat
victims and what impact that do have for
the capacity of law enforcement to
actually make a real difference uh
because we have you know all our
experience and reports show that if
we're successful in supporting and
protection support and protection to
victims law enforcement can do a better
job because you know this these are
communicating um elements and then the
third one would be also then prosecution
and prosecution you know in for to that
to to to be effective again if we can
work better and have some better
legislation in terms of uh Prosecuting
uh the users of of uh of trafficking
victims uh to go after legal entities so
a company or uh you know a legal entity
that is part taking part in this
exploitation they would be legally um uh
liable so issues like this we have put
you know the ambition a little bit
higher in the parliament now we're
negotiating where we're going to end up
so uh I'm hopeful we will be able to
finish but it's clear that
we do start as is often the case these
two institutions with a little bit
different
points of course any such a case any
case of human trafficking is a great tra
tragedy but could you please tell us
more about the scale of this problem uh
how big it is and is it on on the rise
or maybe we are going we are heading
into the right direction but uh we need
to move
faster uh I I think uh I'm always
careful with with figures but it's it's
clear that we see uh uh that this is a
phenomena where there is a lot of
non-reported cases so the reported cases
I would say is just just the the more
visible part of the problem we know that
there's a lot of more trafficking going
on and I think what what we do know is
that we have you know of course
trafficking from outside the EU into the
EU but we have more than half is inside
the EU because trafficking is you know a
crime that involves deceit uh it means
you know um and and that that you are
luring victims into this coercion and
and these issues and you don't have to
be outside the EU to for this to happen
you have I think this is typically a
crime that strives on people's
vulnerability and your vulnerability is
is is an um a consequence of of many
issues it can be of gender inequality of
lack of opportunities it can be of you
know lack of ch protection mechanisms it
can be because of sometimes because of
racism of of marginalization of certain
communities and that that makes you
vulnerable for traffickers they will go
and they will they will you know profit
from that vulnerability but in the end
there's also somebody using and the user
in in this new proposal from the
commission and also from the parliament
we want to criminalize The Knowing use
of Services of a trafficking victims
because what you know the vulnerability
wouldn't end up in a crime unless the
user was in the other end uh um in the
end um uh situation H and typically you
know the parliament position for example
the majority of trafficking in in human
beings in in in Europe is for sexual
exploitation so trafficked women into
Broad and to be be exploited and and
abused and in that we in the parliament
position we say very clearly that the
sex buyers the ones that go into there
and that they buy women and girls that
are victims of trafficking they should
be directly uh legally uh liable for
that H and some countries they are
against that direct legal liability but
I strongly believe that that is the way
forward because in countries like Sweden
like Norway Ireland countries where we
have criminalized the the the purch of
sexual Services trafficking has also
gone down H and what we are proposing is
that even if those countries that don't
want to criminalize all forms of sex
buying which I think would be the right
thing to do but if at least those all
countries should criminalize the buying
of sexual Services of a trafficking
victim so that's that should be a
minimum standard but we are having
negotiations with Council on this and
and some member states are not on
board okay I I understand that this is
not your position but could you please
explain the logic behind not wanting uh
purchasing of
uh sex sex I don't know how to how to
even put that put that I mean what's the
logic be beh behind the opposition
towards such a such a law to prohibit
people from buying uh you know sex
workers that are that are of that are
victims of human traffickers I mean
what's the what's the reasoning what's
the logic behind behind this
opposition uh I think the I think the
the big uh reason for that is that they
have a very strong countries like
Germany Netherlands but also to some
extent Belgium have a very strong
institutionalized uh prostitution
industry and they they are they're
strong voices because uh in the end uh
uh even you know I I think no woman's
body should be commodified I think
that's the best way to protect all women
you know h of different you know walks
of life but at least you know you we
should be able to agree on that you you
it should not be uh possible or it
should be uh prohibited to buy a sex
trafficking victim H the reasons that
they come up with I don't think they're
not logical they're not reasonable it's
it's just it's just a position that that
doesn't make sense and I think countries
like like Germany is willing to to move
in in our Direction in the direction of
the European Parliament position uh we
will see how it goes uh uh but in the
end whatever the outcome of this this
negotiations are in the end countries
will be able to adopt more Progressive
legislation and I think you know
Progressive in this sense must be to
safeguard the rights of girls and women
not to be
abused oh hearing from member of
European Parliament that the position of
some countries in European Council can
be led by uh industry of prostitution is
is is scary I think for it should be car
for for many Europeans especially young
Europeans and and women uh but you you
you told um something about technology
and technology is of course something
that uh changes everything it changes
also how human traffickers uh operate so
how we should adapt to that what we
should do and how this new law is uh
going to address that yeah just to come
back to I I'm not saying that you know
this interest in the prostitution
industry that they would run the
political Affairs of think that's that's
not the the situation but I think people
are naive about the situation in in that
that that in brel and that you know some
people don't want to see the abuse that
actually goes on there so I I think
that's that's maybe more part of the
problem but uh when it comes to the
online Dimension I think it's very clear
that a lot of of trafficking goes on
there that's where you know you you the
traffickers go to find the vulnerability
of people of of of young of of you know
even miners uh of people that are in a
vable situation so we have to make sure
that we articulate that responsibility
also and that if you if you as a user
also then are um having this online um
the abuse starts online we can be able
to act also on that level again uh this
is a sector that is sensitive for member
states to regulate around uh and we also
have other legal instruments the Digital
Services act and others and we make we
also have to make sure that we don't
overlap and make contradictory
legislation so we're working on that but
it's very clear I think it's clear for
law enforcement that of course we have
to work with the online Dimension more
actively so human trafficking is almost
by definition an international problem
so it seems impossible for European
Union to solve this problem without
cooperation of European countries so
what should we do to urge countries to
really cooperate on this matter to to
cooperate so that we can really
eliminate this not in you cannot
eliminate this procedure in in in in one
country so so what can we do to push
countries to to cooperate I think we see
a uh quite good cooperation with third
countries uh actually on the issue of
trafficking because uh it's it's not
it's like with the intra EU trafficking
which is the majority as I said but the
ex external EU it's the same you know
have you have people in in vulnerability
situation and then there is a demand
that that is is the you know the that
wants to use this vulnerability so as
European Union of course we have to work
to reduce vulnerability of the the
countries of origion and that means to
support gender equality to support
livelihood uh um projects Etc but we
also then have to work with with the the
demand reduction H in in the European
Union and it means to work when it comes
to trafficking for labor exploitations
to work with trade trade unions to to
make sure that we don't have Labor
exploitation of trafficking victims in
Europe in 2023 it means that we have to
use uh the different tools to say well
you cannot uh you cannot um abuse uh
women trafficking victims in uh in
prostitution so we have to be clear
about reducing the demand but at the
same time reducing vulnerability in
third
countries MP Malin B thank you so much
for your time and my name is Martin Kush
thank you for your attention goodbye and
see you next time thank
you